parfait bonjour bonjour monsieur Bruce
nous allons commencer mes chers
collègues avant que nous commencions nos
auditions je vous rappelle les deux
déplacements qui vont se tenir la
semaine prochaine et la suivante auquel
vous êtes chaleureusement convié les
collègues nous vous rendrons dans les
Vosges lundi 3 avril et un autre en
Haute-Garonne le jeudi 13 avril et
aujourd'hui notre mission on va
s'attacher à deux catégories de communes
alors dans un premier temps les communes
de montagne et dans un deuxième temps à
partir du 18h les communes ultramarines
il est en effet important pour nous de
prendre la mesure des spécificités
territoriales auxquelles ces communes
sont confrontées d'examiner leur
conséquences sur leur fonctionnement ou
l'exercice du mandat municipal
alors nous commençons donc par les
communes de montagne et avant de passer
la parole à notre rapporteur pour cette
première table ronde je salue nos
invités alors en présentiel ici Madame
Alice Morel maire de Bellefosse dans le
barème présidente de l'association du
massif vosgien membre du comité
directeur de la NEM association
nationale des élus de la montagne
monsieur Gilles gremieux maire
d'Orpierre dans les Hautes-Alpes et
Madame Christine portevais maire de
Guillestre dans les Hautes-Alpes aussi
et nous avons en visio-conférence donc
Monsieur André mirmerde
Saint-Lary-Soulan dans les
Hautes-Pyrénées et Madame Anissa mère de
Luz-Saint-Sauveur aussi dans les
Hautes-Pyrénées
et nous attendons monsieur Sébastien
Pradier président des mers ruraux de
l'Ardèche qui devrait se connecter
alors pour pour vous rappeler rapidement
le cadre de cette mission mesdames et
messieurs cette mission a été mise en
place il y a quelques semaines elle est
composée d'une vingtaine de sénateurs
chez l'honneur de la présidé et Mathieu
d'Arnaud donc et année le rapporteur
c'est une mission qui a pour but de
proposer une vision à horizon 2030 de la
commune et des mers et c'est pour ça
qu'on a souhaité vous entendre pour
cerner vos attentes vos difficultés et
aussi peut-être analyser les raisons
d'une éventuelle crise de vocation qui
est qui semble se profiler un petit peu
avec aujourd'hui près de 900 maires qui
ont démissionné déjà depuis
2020 depuis leur réélection alors
Mesdames et Messieurs votre témoignage
sera précieux à notre mission et non
seulement pour nous aider à comprendre
les difficultés que vous rencontrez dans
l'exercice de votre mandat et qui sont
propres aux caractéristiques des
territoires de montagne mais aussi pour
enviser envisager avec vous les réponses
qui pourraient être apportées assez
difficultés et je vais de suite laisser
la parole à mon collègue Mathieu Darnaud
pour tenir question puis nous laisserons
ensuite la parole à Madame madame Morel
pour une introduction titre de la NEM
merci madame la Présidente chère Maryse
je vais pas longer le propos parce que
nous sommes un peu plus nombreux que
d'habitude ce soir et comme vous faites
l'honneur de votre présence et je salue
aussi celles et ceux qui sont en visio
je préfère tout de suite vous céder la
parole en vous demandant si possible et
de bien prendre en compte
les deux piliers qu'on souhaite vraiment
vous voir aborder le premier c'est
vraiment ce qui aujourd'hui dans
l'exercice de votre mandat
singulièrement parce que vous êtes
toutes et tous issus de territoires de
montagne donc avec une spécificité une
proline Matic particulière
peut constituer des des freins à
l'exercice du mandat et à l'opposé
qu'est-ce qui selon vous continuez
finalement
à motiver votre votre engagement et puis
vraiment cet autre pilier puisque Marie
Carrère le rappelait à l'instant notre
volonté c'est un peu de voir comment
préfigurer de la commune à horizon 2030
avec bien sûr en prenant en compte le
retour d'expérience qu'il vôtre le lien
singulier et particulier et fort que
vous avez avec vos habitants aux
populations respectives et aussi
traduire par la même vos attentes voilà
un petit peu ce que nous souhaitons
aussi recueillir de votre part ce soir
en vous remerciant à nouveau de votre
présence
juste j'ai oublié de vous préciser que
ce cette audition est retransmise en
direct sur le site du Sénat et sera
disponible ensuite un rediffusion donc
c'était pour bien vous le préciser
madame la Présidente aujourd'hui qui
représentait la présidente de
l'Association nationale des élus de la
montagne
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs madame messieurs aussi chers
collègues
je pense d'emblée que quand on nous pose
la question de l'avenir de la commune et
du maire cela sous-entend certainement
que son avenir est menacé un tant soit
peu alors menacé si nous devions en
trouver quatre grandes raisons de
menaces menacé par les transferts
successifs de compétences notamment aux
intercommunalités menacées par la
diminution de de population dans
différents territoires et je pourrais
citer plus précisément un exemple tout à
l'heure du massif des Vosges menacé
aussi par les complexités
administratives et la responsabilité
juridique encaissée et puis menacé aussi
ça c'est sans doute plus récent par le
manque de considération et c'est une
élue qui a plusieurs mandats qui vous
parle et je pense que c'est un ressenti
que nous quand certains membres d'entre
nous ont donc dans dans ce contexte nos
communes de montagne je pense occupent
une place particulière et j'aimerais
rappeler donc au nom de l'Association
nationale des élus de la montagne que
grande petite agricoles touristiques nos
communes de montagne elles sont
exactement aujourd'hui au nombre de
617 6107 communes qui bénéficient de ce
classement elle représente 10% de la
population de notre pays mais par contre
elle représente 25% de sa superficie les
particularités que nous souhaitons
mettre en avant pour l'avenir de nos
communes c'est de rappeler en tout lieu
partout tous les jours que nous avons la
chance depuis près de 40 ans de
bénéficier de la première loi française
qui s'applique à un territoire
spécifique qui en l'occurrence la loi du
janvier 1985 que nous appelons plus
communément la noix montagne une loi qui
reconnaît que nos communes de montagne
ont en commun quelle que soit leur
taille des spécificités la pente le
relief l'altitude le climat des
spécificités des handicats de fait en
termes d'accessibilité en termes de
développement en termes d'aménagement
mais aussi un grand nombre d'atouts je
pense qu'il faut mettre en avant les
paysages notre agriculture de montagne
ces forêts ses ressources en eau les
atouts sont également nombreux et bien
sûr la nécessaire protection de ces
territoires d'un grand nombre d'espace
or ce que nous constatons suite à cette
loi c'est que peu de service dans les
ministères dans nos régions dans nos
départements peu d'interlocuteurs dans
les services de l'État font référence au
quotidien à cette loi pour venir en
appui à nos communes de montagne et
pourtant cette loi de gentils 1985 a été
suivi par une deuxième loi en décembre
2016 donc très récemment qui réaffirme
et qui renforce ses spécificités aussi
pour l'avenir j'aurais quelques
suggestions peut-être à faire au niveau
à deux niveaux au niveau par exemple des
finances communales très concrètement ce
qui est intéressant dans dans la
reconnaissance de ses spécificités c'est
que nous avons obtenu la reconnaissance
de la prise en compte du critère voirie
dans les critères retenus pour le calcul
de la DGF aujourd'hui et c'est bien
logique compte tenu des charges et
notamment en période hivernale on
pourrait imaginer pour l'avenir pour
pour tenir compte non pas de doubler
mais d'améliorer ce critère pourquoi pas
le triplet l'autre suggestion c'est la
dotation et lu locale pour les plus
petites communes là aussi si cette
dotation était améliorée je pense que
ces deux mesures permettraient en partie
bien sûr d'atténuer aussi la diminution
de la DGF diminution de la DGF qui est
due dans certains territoires à la
diminution de la population
il se serait à mon avis plus juste
reconnaissances de l'action des communes
des maires au service du quotidien des
habitants et en plus je pense que ces
deux critères ne devraient pas mettre en
péril des finances de l'État
toujours dans le registre des finances
faciliter l'accès aux aides on peut se
réjouir nous les maires des communes
quand on nous annonce qu'il y a une
enveloppe de la tetr qui est abondée
c'est une bonne nouvelle néanmoins quand
les dossiers de DETR arrivent jusqu'à
nos communes et à nos sous-préfet
difficile pour un maire de monter un
dossier quand on nous annonce que le
taux d'aide aussi entre 20 et 80%. c'est
tout de même pas la même chose si on est
retenu à hauteur de 20%, ou à hauteur de
80%. donc je pense que là aussi si on
pouvait donner un signe fort en
privilégiant les dossiers communaux et
en apportant aussi au dossier communaux
un taux de 10% supplémentaires dès
l'instant où ce sont des dossiers qui
émanent de communes de montagne
enfin ce schéma s'il était mis en place
par l'État pourrait peut-être aussi
encourager nos élus départementaux et
nos élus régionaux de faire de même et
de mieux prendre en considération c'est
plus petites communes et ses communes de
deux montagnes voilà ce que je voulais
dire pour les finances l'autre volet
c'est de réaffirmer la commune comme
premier échelon de proximité et le maire
comme première interlocuteur nous
l'avons tous vu ces dernières années
notamment au niveau des crises
climatiques on peut prendre les tempêtes
on peut prendre les routes effondrées
les inondations les incendies qui mieux
que le maire qui mieux que les adjoints
les membres du conseil municipal on la
connaissance du territoire la
connaissance des moyens humains pour
venir en aide on peut dire la même chose
pour la crise sanitaire on a vu que les
solidarités de proximité les solidarités
villageoises ont été très nombreuses et
particulièrement dans les secteurs
isolés que ce soit pour l'organisation
des courses pendant le confinement que
ce soit pour la prise de rendez-vous par
exemple pour les premières vaccinations
pour les publics les plus fragiles
en conclusion dans les villes on
développe des politiques de quartier on
développe des journées citoyennes des
fêtes des voisins on flèche des budgets
participatifs pour rapprocher l'action
publique des citoyens nous dans nos
communes nous avons la chance de la
proximité nous avons la chance de la
connaissance du territoire et bien
éloigner des grands centres urbains nous
savons aussi nous bénéficions aussi des
services numériques aujourd'hui et
savons les utiliser donc je pense qu'il
faudrait aujourd'hui mettre tout en
oeuvre pour peut-être au niveau des
réformes appuyez sur le bouton pause
pour les transferts obligatoires des
compétences afin de conserver notre
spécificité française qui est une
organisation communale proche des
habitants piliers de la démocratie et
surtout dans un pays où on a vu ces
dernières années les réformes
successives qui se sont mises en place
ou qu'avons-nous fait on a agrandi les
périmètres des intercommunalités là où
il y avait trois quatre cinq cantons on
en fait plus qu'un donc on éloigne les
élus départementaux si l'on regarde la
sociologie des élus régionaux se sont
souvent les mers des grandes villes ou
les présidents des grandes
intercommunalités qui a 80% sont les
élus régionaux donc le seul élu qui
reste le plus proche ça reste le maire
et pour toutes ces raisons je pense moi
j'ai confiance en l'avenir de la commune
et je vous remercie pour cette
initiative
merci beaucoup merci on va juste saluer
l'arrivée de Monsieur Sébastien Pradier
qui nous a rejoint en visioconférence
merci merci Monsieur le Maire
on va peut-être alterner un petit peu
avec la visio
si on va te laisser la parole à Madame
Sani comme elle était
connectée la première
lasagne si vous pouviez vous êtes
nouvelle mère parce que vous êtes vous
avez été lu il y a quelques mois un
remplacement du maire du maire qui a
démissionné
c'est intéressant aussi d'avoir un oeil
neuf pour votre votre œil tout neuf même
si vous étiez adjointe déjà de votre
commune mais d'avoir aussi votre vision
depuis que vous êtes maire des
difficultés auxquelles vous êtes
confrontés et surtout la différence
peut-être entre le poste d'adjoint et le
poste de maire
pour l'instant je suis la moins
expérimentée de des mères qui
participent à cette vision en
conférences donc j'ai je n'ai pas
vraiment du recul pour en parler mais
le poste d'adjoint que j'occupais
que j'étais très impliquée déjà donc la
différence n'est pas si énorme que ça
par contre
les difficultés qu'on rencontre dans les
communes de montagne
viennent selon moi de la géographie et
qui est plus complexe et des distances
qu'il faut gérer du décalage des enjeux
entre les zones très touristiques et
celles qui le sont moins avec des
discussions du coup qui sont très
compliquées et du découpage des interco
comme ça vient d'être dit qui est
souvent un inadéquation avec les
variations économiques et que nous
connaissons dans les dans les villages
touristiques donc ça c'était vrai quand
j'étais adjointe c'est vrai depuis que
je suis mère
c'est vrai que si je devais dire
ce qui me touche en tant que mère c'est
peut-être de voir la difficulté
des mères face à la prolifération en
normative qui fait que on doit tricoter
des tricoter toujours des contraintes
légales pour être sûr d'être dans le bon
cadre et
en tenant compte toujours de nos
difficultés propres donc ça veut dire
que ça induit beaucoup de technicité
d'encadrement dès qu'il peut assez
solide et ça c'est quand même difficile
dans des petites communes nous ne sommes
que que enfin moins de 1000 habitants
930 habitants voilà ce que je dirais par
contre je souscris avec le même
enthousiasme l'importance au rôle majeur
du maire dans sa mission
sa proximité c'est vraiment le maillon
qui on s'est rendu compte pendant le
covid à quel point le rôle une mère est
essentielle dans la relation avec les
administrés et je pense que c'est moi je
suis très confiante aussi parce que je
pense qu'il y a un petit peu un
rétropédalage après l'avoir un peu
oublié on le remet en scène on recroît
en son rôle essentiel et je souhaite
comme beaucoup d'entre nous je pense
qu'on revienne à lui donner de plus en
plus de missions et que et qu'on limite
les compétences des intercos à des
compétences transversales qui touchent
peut-être tout le monde mais mais moins
élargi
ok peut-être monsieur Crémieu
je suis maire depuis 2020 et je n'avais
pas de mandat avant d'une commune rurale
du Sud des Hautes-Alpes qui s'appelle
Orpierre alors cette commune a chance
d'être entourée de falaises et d'avoir
eu dans les années 80 des bénévoles des
passionnés qui ont bien avant que cela
devienne à la mode ont eu le flair de la
grimpe de l'escalade et donc c'est
désormais le la Mecque un peu de de la
grimpe en témoigne ce numéro j'en
profite bien évidemment c'est le rôle
aussi un des rôles du maire je suis
arrivé là
d'abord parce que c'était la vallée et
le berceau de de maligné maternelle
je suis arrivé là après 13 ans
d'enseignement
25 ans à la direction d'un groupe de
presse régionale Centre France la
montagne c'est dire que des élus j'en ai
côtoyé des grands des petits et que
sans doute ça m'a donné envie de passer
de l'autre côté de la barrière ne plus
les voir avec le regard médiatique mais
de le vivre de le vivre moi-même en plus
toute ma vie a été marquée par un
engagement associatif multiple
récurrents alors c'est encore en milieu
rural une balance monture
il est encore quelqu'un j'allais dire
comme le médecin le curé mais il y a
plus de médecin et le curé mais cette
image pagnollesque reste en partie vrai
dans nos petites communes rurales mais
si on analyse cette image un peu
idyllique elle ne résiste pas longtemps
il y a bord ce constat de profonde
mutation de notre société et les
comportements de nos concitoyens
le respect traditionnellement affiché de
l'élu comme un notable
a laissé la place à une exigence
véhémente de tous les instants le moi je
parce que c'est moi et bien l'emporte
beaucoup souvent trop souvent sur la
solidarité et sur le sens
collectif et le maire c'est sa première
mission quand il traverse la place du
village c'est de régler le problème dans
les meilleurs délais
il y a ensuite ce sentiment que c'est
plus qu'un sentiment d'ailleurs que
dépend des compétences qui contribuent à
son autorité ou qui contribue à son
autorité son petit à petit dévolu à la
communauté de communes
à l'intercommunalité or notre communauté
de communes compte 60 communes sur trois
départements et se transfert de
compétences s'il peut apparaître
rationnel à quelques esprits
technocatrices technocratiques n'en est
pas moins préjudiciable dans l'évolution
des responsabilités c'est de plus en
plus lointains et de plus en plus
anonymes alors que le maire on le voit
il faut parler aussi du désarroi ou de
son désarroi d'un petit maire je sais
que ma collègue elle a la chance d'avoir
dans une commune plus importante
responsable des services mais il y a un
désarroi des mers devant cette avalanche
de sollicitations pour des projets ou
subventions
certes on pourrait s'en réjouir je crois
réellement qu'il y a des efforts qui
sont faits pour
lancer des appels assurance mais dans
une petite commune ni le maire en
premier lieu ni le personnel n'est
suffisamment formé pour
même si les associations de type AMF
font font des efforts mais le maire
n'est pas assez formé pour construire
dans un minimum de temps un dossier qui
doit être tenait avec le plan vert qui
doit être plus vert que vert
c'est compliqué ça demande des des
chiffres ça demande des analyses
généralement quand on arrive au terme de
nos hésitations et bien d'autres sont
déjà passés je lisais ce matin dans la
MF que le ministre félicité que le plan
vert était déjà au-delà de ses moyens
enfin de son enveloppe
alors c'est vrai qu'il y a ce problème
d'ingénierie et
l'ingénierie certes dans notre
département à la chance d'être soutenu
par conseil départemental en somme les
salariés du conseil départemental sont
en même temps les salariés d'une
structure qui s'appelle it et qui est au
service des communes néanmoins ce
système assez limite il est parfois long
il y a parfois embouteillage dans les
demandes et
il ne vous mâche pas non plus tout le
tas de fait le travail
il y a aussi un aspect dans le quotidien
du maire c'est l'avalanche
de réunion
syndicat de rivière syndicat
d'électricité parc naturel régional
communauté de communes il faut être à
toutes ces réunions mais ces
chronophages et c'est vraiment un
fardeau lourd à porter notamment là
encore pour les petits mères qui ne
peuvent pas
répartir ces interventions
et puis un désorient en fin devant le
manque de moyens financiers
pour réaliser les projets notamment
quand on est jeune mère vous imaginez
bien vous le savez bien vous l'avez sans
doute vécu qu'on arrive avec des bruits
de révolutionner la commune et là je
vais faire ça et là où là ils ont été je
vais faire mieux etc bon très vite on
est chante quand même la réalité nous
ramène
à la raison et il y a un manque de
moyens notamment on l'a DGF reste pour
moi une alchimie secrète
qui ne permet pas aux maires de faire
évoluer sa demande moi je pensais
naïvement angéliquement que en faisant
classer ma commune
en commune touristique puisqu'elle passe
de 250 habitants l'hiver 2000 quasiment
l'été ceci en montagne on n'est pas on
n'est pas sur la côte je pensais que ça
attirerait l'attention ou qu'il y aurait
un traitement spécifique de la DGF pour
ce type de situation et bien il n'en est
rien et là je crois que c'est un sujet
sur lequel il faut il faut se pencher
alors je reconnais que depuis le covid
voir un peu les gilets jaunes les
pouvoirs publics ont redécouvert le
caractère et mes collègues
présente Madame Morel le disait que
évidemment le rôle
irremplaçable du maire de par sa
proximité avec les citoyens est enfin un
peu reconnu je note il faut le l'avouer
que la relation notamment
avec la préfecture on parle du couple
préférée a évolué indiscutablement des
instructions sans doute venues
conforter cette ce besoin mais c'est
vrai qu'un préfet est allé est à
l'écoute et que j'ai le sentiment que le
bonheur de donner au chef de service est
quand même d'être dans la mesure du
possible un autre un autre écoute
mais cela ne règle pas le problème des
normes de cette avalanche des normes
aussi qui qui nous viennent
des directives
sont souvent édifiés par des gens qui
n'ont pas vécu au quotidien ce qu'est
une commune rurale et ce qu'est
et ce qu'est une commune de Montagne on
pourrait citer des exemples l'urbanisme
sur le bernisme quand vous faites un PLU
on vous dit bon ben écoutez on prend les
chiffres de ce qui s'est passé depuis 10
ans et puis on projette sur les 10 ans à
venir mais c'est un rythme éthique là ne
tient pas compte des dynamiques le maire
précédent avait pu ne pas se faire
d'effort pour accueillir quelqu'un le
maire suivant a peut-être envie
justement d'accueillir beaucoup plus de
monde et il est bloqué parce qu'on lui
dit mais non regardez vous avez consommé
qu'un hectare l'année dernière donc
enfin dans les 10 ans précédant pardon
et donc on va pas vous en donner
beaucoup plus
ça je crois que on pourrait parler aussi
de l'eau on parlait des compétences mais
je pense que mes collègues ils
reviendront mais mais la compétence de
l'eau est quelque chose de sacré
dans le quotidien du maire la fuite
d'eau je suis désolé la fuite d'eau
c'est un des éléments marquants c'est un
des curseurs qui
qui situe le maire il s'occupe de l'eau
il y a une fuite je vais le voir l'autre
le passé comme le prévoit la loi en 2016
aux intercommunalités
je crois que nous regrettons parce que
c'est nous enlever encore une légitimité
c'est encore nous enlever du pouvoir
leur je dis pas qu'il faut refaire la
loi je dis qu'il doit y avoir simplement
c'est mon sentiment tout au moins qui
doit y avoir un peu une un transfert à
la carte qui est une liberté c'est à
dire que dans certains cas parce que les
cas sont pas identiques je veux bien
comprendre qu'un petit maire d'une du
bassin parisien n'est pas du tout le
même raisonnement que le mien mais dans
une commune de Montagne vous avez votre
source et c'est sacré votre source et
vous vous guettez déjà sur le terrain de
la pub suivante sera libre parce que
vous êtes inquiet sur les 20 ans qui
viennent je crois que ça il faut nous
laisser parce que n'importe comment
quand il y a une chute d'eau il y a
aucun numéro de téléphone qui sonne
c'est celui du maire c'est pas celui de
l'adjoint c'est pas celui du conseil
municipal c'est celui du maire et en
disant qu'est-ce que tu peux faire tout
de suite et c'est pas en disant mais
attendez les services sont fermés
rappelés lundi à 9h que on réglera le
problème là je crois que on fait fausse
route alors pour conclure
que sera le mai en 2030 et bien j'ai une
inquiétude c'est que petit à petit le
maire pour 2030 soit un guichet unique
des pleurs des mécontentement sans
aucune de bons endroits mais sans aucune
possibilité d'avoir le pouvoir qui
devrait aller en face parce que nos
citoyens nous voient comme celui qui a
dû pouvoir celui qui peut régler des
problèmes et si on nous enlève ces
pouvoirs et bien on sera perdu
merci merci beaucoup
monsieur mire peut-être de Saint-Lary
Soula s'il peut rajouter quelque chose
mais je suis sûre qu'il partage ce
qu'ils viennent d'être maudit
[Musique]
il y a plus de son
tu nous entends
bon on va passer à l'heure peut-être à
oui donc c'est pas notre niveau c'est
chez eux ça marche chez nous
vous nous entendez pas
non bon on va laisser madame Portevin
peut-être oui
madame Portevin en attendant que le
souci se trouve une solution on va
vous laisser la parole madame la mère de
Guillestre merci merci pour
merde une commune de 2400 habitants dans
les Hautes-Alpes qui s'appelle
Guillestre c'est une je suis maire
depuis 2020 mais j'avais déjà demandé
électoraux municipaux avant j'ai été
conseillé municipal puis 1er adjointe
mais contrairement à collègue je pense
que le rôle du maire et la différence
entre première adjointe et mère c'est
énorme voilà le téléphone sonne beaucoup
plus parce que les gens ont vraiment
envie que ce soit le même à 2400
habitants ils ont vraiment envie que ce
soit le maire qui soit là
on a la chance d'être une commune
touristique une chance et donc
saisonnière
je fais partie donc
je continue
euh donc oui on a on a la chance d'être
dans une commune de Montagne on a envie
de mettre d'altitude entre deux stations
de ski entre Vars et Risoul et le Kera
donc est un bijou
naturel et très très beau avec aussi des
stations de ski le parc du carat on est
à 64 % dans le tarte du Kera donc on a
vraiment un bijoux géographique et de
paysages comme vous disiez tout à
l'heure on est une petite ville de
demain je sais que ça avait pas de
l'unanimité mais on a une petite ville
de demain une petite ville de centralité
on possède un centre historique
moyenâgeux une centaine de commerces et
d'industrie des services publics encore
un peu grâce à France services un cinéma
communal une crèche communale un centre
de vacances communale un camping
communal une auberge communale une
piscine estivale une quarantaine
d'associations actives et soutenue par
la commune deux écoles communales un
collège cinq hameaux et c'est quand même
énorme
ça c'est la jolie photo de ma commune
mais il y a quand on ouvre un peu la
vitrine et qu'on y regarde de plus près
il y a quand même quelques ombres sur la
photo on a 40 % de logements de
résidence secondaire
donc vide la plupart du temps
dans le centre ancien 14% de logements
vacants et souvent un salubre un grand
trou béant au milieu du village c'est la
cicatrice de l'effondrement d'une maison
trop vétuste depuis 2014 le président
qui a été fermé après une étude
structure inquiétante des saisonniers en
camion qui n'ont pas de terrain pour
vivre l'hiver et qui ont qui occupe un
terrain communal une trésorerie qui a
déménagé à une vingtaine de kilomètres
des logements trop chers pour que nos
jeunes s'y installent une fermeture de
classe il y a deux ans et une autre il y
a 4 ans
le paysage est joli mais le portrait est
dressé voilà là dedans on a toutes les
difficultés et je reprends un petit peu
ce que ce que disait mes collègues
l'écharpe du maire c'est un symbole de
la République française mais parfois
elle est un peu lourde à porter enfin
c'est un budget toujours plus contraint
à des normes toujours plus
incompréhensibles et déconnectés de la
réalité je parlerai
je parlerai du nombre de classes ou de
l'éloignement de l'éducation nationale
des classes fermées des enfants qui se
lèvent le matin et qui font 20 km dans
la 3 ans voilà des normes voilà c'est
des chiffres la valeur du chiffre
des administrés toujours plus renfermés
sur leur sourcils personnel leur nombril
et c'est compliqué à gérer quand on
émerve à une société qui conteste bien
commun et les règles du bien vivre
ensemble à une crise démocratique moi
qui m'effraie je pense qu'il y en a
vraiment une à l'éloignement des
services publics qui créent de la
frustration à des violences verbales de
plus en plus quotidiennes et à des
responsabilités toujours plus lourdes
pour pallier au manque d'action de
l'état parfois
je pense que heureusement on a on est je
crois quand même dans le rôle du merle
même si je dresse un drapeau un tableau
noir même si je suis pas sûr de me
représenter en 2026
je ne suis pas sûr aujourd'hui à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui
mais je crois que cette cette fonction
elle est elle est très importante
quand il y a le côté positif l'équilibre
familial ça c'est personnel une équipe
municipale investie et sur le terrain
une équipe d'agents comme vous disiez
parce que l'ingénierie du travail il y a
des dossiers à remplir on a 65 g65
agents municipaux à Guillestre chez un
manager sans l'avoir appris donc voilà
je suis un DRH et je mène une équipe que
voilà je sais pas faire mais j'apprends
sur le terrain parfois c'est difficile
il faut aussi des des
financeurs proches je parle du
département qui est notre premier
financeur et celui qui est le plus à
l'écoute enfin moi je trouve le plus
proche de nous
après trois années de mandat de mer et
demanda de mandat municipaux je me rends
compte que la charge qui repose sur le
premier magistrat de la commune était
énorme le maire doit être à l'écoute des
citoyens mais aussi entendre leur
demande et leur proposition il doit être
dans le concret mais aussi avoir une
vision à long terme il doit réaliser des
projets mais respecter un budget défini
par d'autres que lui sans trop de marge
de manœuvre il fait des choix pour
l'avenir et c'est cela qui fait la force
du mandat et sa fragilité par sa grande
responsabilité
juste insister sur peut-être on ne
reviendra après sur l'intercommunalité
qui est effectivement moi je dans mon
analyse qui éloigne également
la crise de la vie politique et peu de
gens qui viennent voter je pense que
l'éloignement des compétences et
également du enfin c'est une des causes
je pense de ça les gens ne voient pas
l'intérêt et quand il y a un problème de
l'assainissement même si là comme comme
ils viennent quand même à la commune il
y a pas de problème là c'est le maire
qui s'appelle aussi
voilà c'est un beau mandat mais voilà il
faut il faut avoir être costaud
merci Madame le Maire
vous avez sûrement récupéré la connexion
on vous nous entendait maintenant donc
on va passer la parole à Monsieur mir et
puis on terminera
ensuite par l'Ardèche
bonjour tout le monde donc je vais
essayer de partager le temps de parole
alors peut-être brièvement rappeler le
contexte même si un certain nombre de
choses dont on était dites concernant
les complexités administratives vous
avez beaucoup parlé des normes il y a
quand même des chiffres qui sont
édifiants actuellement ma mère est
confronté faut-il le rappeler pas moins
de 400 000 normes le code général des
collectivités publiques on est passé
2012 à quelque chose comme 300 et
quelques mille mots un million de mots
donc c'est dire quand même cette
difficulté qui est vraiment qui qui nous
affecte de manière très sensible les
contraintes administratives également
environnementales c'est clair que
lorsque une commune porte un projet
vertueux qui va dans le sens de la
protection de la biodiversité
développement durable etc etc nous
sommes soumises à des contraintes qui
sont difficiles
difficilement compréhensible je pourrais
donner certaines nombre d'exemples et
quand il s'agit par exemple de remplacer
un groupe électrogène qui
comment dirais-je utiliser par un refuge
par une Pico centrale on a les pires
difficultés pour faire aboutir aboutir
ces projets il faut plusieurs années
et puis tout ça fait que actuellement
par rapport à il y a quelques années
conduire un projet actuellement c'est un
projet un peu structurant s'entend c'est
de l'ordre il y a quelques années en
deux heures on pouvait arriver
effectivement à finaliser ce projet
alors après je crois que ce que la
Commission attend peut-être des
témoignages des maires ces exemples
concrets
pour que mamierais-je bien
bien apprécier les difficultés
auxquelles sont confrontées les maires
de les mers et les maires de montagne en
particulier s'agissant de la fiscalité
ce qu'il faut quand même je pense que
mon propos sera partagé c'est que nous
ne disposons plus de levier fiscaux
hormis bien sûr le fait de d'augmenter
les taux de la fiscalité ménage donc peu
de peu de possibilités à ce niveau là
bon on a beaucoup de difficultés en
l'occurrence pour comment dirais-je
pratiquer l'augmentation sur la taxe
d'habitation des résidences secondaires
parce que nous sommes pas à ce jour
connus comme une commune présentant au
marché financier tendus alors même que
dernières opérations qui sont faites sur
mon territoire on était quand même à
1600 euros du mètre carré ce qui est
parié voilà donc ça c'est une première
difficulté puisque sans ressource bien
évidemment en difficulté à conduire et
réaliser des structurant autre exemple
dans le domaine du l'urbanisme avec
cette fameuse loi Zane qui qui
s'applique de manière uniforme sur
l'ensemble du territoire alors que dans
ma commune
[Musique]
l'artificialisation des sols ça
représente à peine 1,2 % de mon
territoire alors que tout le reste est
classé en site naturel site classé comme
une adhérente la charte du Parc National
et on a beaucoup on va avoir beaucoup de
difficultés pour conduire des projets
notamment social dans le domaine de
l'urbanisme également
ce que l'on souhaiterait c'est un
assouplissement au niveau de la
procédure de révision simplifiée
lorsqu'il s'agit de corriger une erreur
matérielle on engage une procédure de
résidence révision simplifiée qui peut
durer plusieurs plusieurs mois bon on a
évoqué l'interco bon je j'en parle parce
que ce que j'observe c'est que dans les
intercommunalités voisines j'ai pas le
sentiment que le bilan soit totalement
satisfaisant elle s'en fout on a plutôt
l'impression de trouver de d'une couche
supplémentaire qui a pour effet
d'entraver le processus de décision et
qui n'apporte pas de valeur aux plantes
de la mutualisation des moyens sur le
plan du logement permanent qui est un
souci pour les les communes touristiques
de montagne là aussi on est confronté à
des difficultés dans la mesure où le
dispositif législatif n'est pas n'est
pas au rendez-vous puisque pour pour ont
réalisé par exemple une opération de
logements social selon la formule du
bail réel solidaire il faut être reconnu
comme zone tendue ce qui est pas ce qui
n'est pas le cas ou alors il faut
effectivement être inscrit sur la
fameuse hélice qui a fait l'objet
récemment d'une communication
au titre aussi des difficultés que l'on
peut rencontrer c'est trouver du
personnel qualifié difficulté de
recrutement du personnel
du personnel territorial pourquoi parce
que lorsqu'on veut faire venir un cadre
ici en fond de vallée se pose le
problème du logement d'une part le
problème
lié au fait qu'il faut trouver du
travail à l'époux ou à l'épouse et quand
on lance les appels d'offres on
s'aperçoit qu'on a très peu de retour et
c'est un véritable sujet parce que
certaines communes touristiques que ce
sont de véritables entreprises donc ont
besoin effectivement de techniciens de
DGS de directeur administratif
financiers
voilà ce que voilà ce que je pourrais
dire pour illustrer effectivement les
difficultés de la fonction de maire une
commune comme la commune de
Saint-Lary-Soulan c'est une entreprise
ça veut dire que les compétences on doit
les retrouver à différents niveaux dans
les services et bien évidemment mais le
maire lui-même il doit être quelque
sorte un couteau suisse qui soit capable
d'appréhender les problématiques propres
au tourisme mais également dans les
domaines de l'organisation de
l'informatique du management
etc donc c'est une fonction c'est vrai
qui est fragilisée qui s'est fragilisé
au fil du temps et
d'autant plus comment dirais c'est
interpelle d'autant plus que les enjeux
sont importants parce que
le principal âgé c'est quand même
l'avenir de ces de ces stations
touristiques de ces communes en fond de
Valais alors pour autant pour autant je
voudrais pas dresser quand même un
tableau une rage trop trop noir et de
cette fonction parce qu'on a malgré tout
des satisfactions et je serai tenté de
dire que c'est encore ça qui nous qui
nous tient et qui nous permet
effectivement
de de rester en pause on peut avoir des
satisfactions par exemple c'est vrai
qu'on parle beaucoup le désert médical
mais quand on a le plaisir quand même de
comment dirais-je de pouvoir créer une
maison de santé avec 27 professionnels
ce qui est le cas dans ma commune c'est
vrai que c'est une satisfaction
intérieure qui qui fait que malgré tout
on est là mais quand même très très
préoccupé par par le devenir de cette de
cette fonction et ce qui n'est pas sans
poser des des problèmes au niveau de la
succession parce que c'est vrai que
alors c'est vrai que le la fonction de
maire elle a une image quand même très
très positive au niveau de la niveau de
la population c'est vrai que le maire
c'est la personne quand même qui est
incontournable alors même que des sujets
ou des problèmes pourraient être traités
par les services ou par des adjoints les
personnes ne veulent voir le maire voilà
parce que c'est effectivement
la personne et qui tiennent toute la
place au niveau de la commune mais c'est
vrai qu'on peut être quand même profité
quand même du devenir de la fonction et
du fait que ça suscite quand même pas
beaucoup de d'intérêt de la part des
jeunes générations parce que au-delà de
ça bon ça a été dit mais c'est d'une
disponibilité 7 jours sur 7 s'agissant
des communes touristiques le travail il
s'arrête pas le pour le maire il
s'arrête pas le vendredi soir parce que
le samedi il a une inauguration il a une
manifestation il a une cérémonie au
monument aux morts il a voilà donc cette
c'est très chronophage et c'est le terme
qui a été exprimé donc moi je souscris
totalement et c'est vrai qu'on peut
s'inquiéter pour pour l'avenir de la
fonction voilà en quelques mots sur le
témoignage que je peux apporter mais il
y aurait bien évidemment bien d'autres
choses à dire et notamment sur le fait
que la spécificité des communes de
montagne n'est pas reconnue dans le
dispositif
législatif vous avez parlé de la
montagne mais alors montagne en fait
comment dirais-je l'Indus pas
d'applications très concrètes
au quotidien et on peut le regretter
donc ce qui serait effectivement
souhaitable c'est que c'est spécificités
elles soient prises en compte en amont
des discussions au moment des
discussions au niveau du Parlement
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Maire de
Saint-Lary foulard on va terminer avec
le maire de gros de géoran en Ardèche
monsieur Sébastien Pradier laisse la
parole oui bonjour
[Musique]
je pense qu'on a ma vie sur le sujet bon
cette fonction je crois qu'elle est
partout dans toutes les petites communes
alors moi je suis maire d'une commune de
165 habitants seulement qui fait 4500
hectares toutes situées à plus de 1000
mètres d'altitude et j'ai 70 km de
voirie communale donc c'est juste pour
poser un peu le cadre voilà je pense que
cette fonction elle est respectée par
tous nos administrés on est en effet le
couteau suisse on fait l'assistante
sociale on fait le chef d'entreprise on
fait le comptable on fait celui qui fait
l'aménagement parce que c'est nous qui
regardons urbanisme
mais les gens la comprennent pas je veux
dire aujourd'hui quand je suis obligé de
refuser un permis de construire
pour quelqu'un qui veut construire sur
le terrain qu'il a hérité de ses
grands-parents parce que l'avoir et il
peut se permettre de construire sa
maison et qui touche les réseaux publics
et la station d'épuration que je suis
obligé de le refuser parce que son
terrain n'appartient pas à la carte
communale c'est quand même décevant et
du coup les gens comprennent mal et du
coup je pense que ça fait ça met cette
distance entre cette fonction et puis
nos administrer qui du coup n'ont plus
de volonté à s'intégrer dans les
conseils municipaux moi j'ai un petit
exemple dans ma commune depuis 1945 il y
a toujours eu de liste en 2020 on était
11 pour 11 places et j'ai mis un moment
pour finir ma liste et les derniers
m'ont dit c'est bien parce que c'est toi
et c'est juste pour t'aider toi combien
est-ce qu'il fait que j'ai aujourd'hui
jamais 11 conseils municipaux au conseil
municipal alors que j'ai été lu adjoint
2008 en 2008 le conseil municipal était
toujours complet les 11 étaient toujours
là ou de 19 ou 2010 et petit à petit on
voit que l'usure arrive quoi
nous on a quand même des difficultés
importantes alors plutôt une commune qui
avait des richesses jadis depuis la le
transfert des impositions communautés de
communes on en a moins puisqu'on a plus
la possibilité d'augmenter ces
ressources et puis le fait que l'État se
désengage quand même fortement moi je
vous en donne juste une preuve en 2008
ma commune touchait 61000 euros de DGF
en 2014 55 en 2020 14 1000 et en 2022 55
euros donc autant vous dire que les
charges de fonctionnement c'est tous que
ce soit autour de la voirie ou de
l'entretien pas diminué en 12 ans et par
contre l'année prochaine je pense que je
vais devoir payer la DGF donc ça c'est
vraiment un vrai problème parce que ben
on sait plus bien équilibré nos budget
de fonctionnement et les communes qui
étaient plutôt riches deviennent pauvres
et quand les riches seront pas je sais
pas ce qui se passera en termes de
communauté de communes puisque moi j'ai
un petit exemple dans notre communauté
de communes on est 28 communes
5000 habitants il faut 2h15 pour aller
d'un boulot à l'autre de la Communauté
de Communes Mathieu d'Arnaud la connaît
bien et les deux communes les plus
importantes ont représentant un quart
des recettes de fonctionnement de cette
communauté de communes et on a deux
voies sur 40 donc autant vous dire que
voilà c'est un peu complexe parfois de
se faire entendre alors même si j'ai la
chance d'être premier vice-président la
communauté de communes et d'avoir de
pouvoir être à l'exécutif et d'entendre
un peu tout ce qui s'est dit mais c'est
parfois compliqué pour pour certains
collègues je pense qui se sentent pas
investis à la communauté de communes et
qui du fait ben voilà on a attaqué notre
communauté de communes à 40 délégués et
aujourd'hui un conseil communautaire
quand on est 25 c'est bien le bout du
monde parce que on est on est on a des
réunions tout autour du ventre et puis
moi je voudrais peut-être ajouter la
difficulté de devenir mère parce que
aujourd'hui on voit bien que être
meilleur jeune moi j'ai été maire à 38
ans mais je suis aussi chef d'entreprise
et j'ai cette chance parce que si
j'étais pas chef d'entreprise que
j'étais ouvrier j'aurais pas pu devenir
mère il y a trop de réunions on passe
trop de temps on passe trop de temps en
journée pour aller aux réunion bien
entendu les services font les réunions
pendant les horaires de service qu'on
peut comprendre et du coup il faut se
dégager trop de temps en journée alors
moi j'ai la chance de diriger mon
entreprise et pouvoir le prendre mais ça
me compliqué et ça me semble être une
cause du désengagement des jeunes dans
la vie publique surtout dans nos petites
communes et on en a bien besoin voilà
bon après moi je suis je suis pas très
confiant sur l'avenir et tout ce qui se
passera en 2030 pour le maire je pense
que dans les petites communes rurales
comme les nôtres il y aura plus de
candidats très clairement moi j'ai une
commune à côté de chez moi ou lui
conseiller municipaux en démissionné et
il trouve pas de gens pour se présenter
pour les remplacer
et puis bon à force de nous enlever les
compétences ben voilà la compétence de
loin est une je veux dire non
on peut pas faire de ne pas faire de la
liaison entre nos communes moi la
commune la plus proche est à 12 km de
chez moi donc j'ai trois réseaux publics
pour alimenter
85 compteurs d'eau donc autant vous dire
que le jour où ça sera géré par la
Communauté de Communes je sais pas
comment ça sera géré mais ça peut pas
marcher quoi donc voilà je pense que il
faut vraiment qu'on arrive à se faire
entendre les mêmes merder petites
communes alors deux montagnes et rurales
c'est peut-être la double peine moi je
préside l'Association des mers euros de
l'Ardèche depuis novembre je veux
essayer de faire entendre ce message on
avait une réunion des présidents hier et
c'est le message que j'ai fait que j'ai
porté quoi c'est que c'est encore plus
difficile dans la ruralité en montagne
j'ai un autre exemple un mètre carré de
terrain dans le sud Ardèche coûte 150
euros constructible chez moi écoute 6
vous voyez un petit peu la disparité
pour arriver à se faire comprendre par
un préfet ou un sous-préfet sur la
volonté d'avoir plus de surface
constructible voilà donc moi je suis pas
très optimiste sur les maires de 2030
mais bon on aura peut-être d'ici là le
temps de se ressaisir et puis peut-être
que globalement on va nous aider au
niveau national
merci merci à toutes et à tous peut-être
avant de laisser la parole au collègue
et on fera peut-être qu'une salle de
questions parce que malheureusement nous
sommes pris par par le temps puisque
nous avons encore notre série
d'auditions derrière moi je voudrais
lancer peut-être là la première question
c'est bien qu'on ait fini par Sébastien
Pradier parce que ça illustre toute la
difficulté et vous l'avez toute et tous
dit entre aujourd'hui les relations au
sein du bloc communal communes
intercommunalité nous l'avons dit en
préambule de nos travaux il y a quelques
semaines notre volonté n'est surtout pas
d'opposer commune et intercommunalité
mais d'opérer quand même un constat de
l'éloignement vous l'avez dit des
compétences et donc de la prise de
décision la dilution justement de de
cette capacité à orienter les décisions
et puis là vous avez un cas d'espèces
vous avez quand même une
intercommunalité
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de recensement
intermédiaire mais dont on sait elle
fait un sixième du département de
en Ardèche et elle est quasiment passée
en dessous des 5000 habitants
c'est-à-dire en dessous de la dérogation
qui imposait la loi notre et quand vous
regardez une carte la Montagne
Ardéchoise c'est là où la Loire prend sa
source on est à côté du Mont Gerbier de
Jean
vous regardez une carte vous savez pas
vraiment à quel autre territoire vous
pouvez la rimer parce que vous êtes sur
les pentes et après vous descendez sur
l'Ardèche Méridionale donc c'est
vraiment on touche du doigt la
complexité ultime de la composition de
l'intercommunalité et puis d'une
géographie qui interdit quasiment
d'avoir une vraie mutualisation au sens
où on peut l'entendre sur d'autres
territoires de France où les communes
sont beaucoup plus rapprochées donc moi
c'est vraiment peut-être reposer une
question sur à l'heure où souvent et il
y a un autre groupe de travail sur la
décentralisation qui qui réfléchit aussi
sur sur l'intercommunalité et donc au
Sénat c'est vrai que c'est un sujet qui
nous anime mais peut-être qu'on arrive à
un temps où de maturité et peut-être
faut-il interroger sur celle des
compétences qui relèvent de la proximité
et donc du maire et puis celles qui sont
plus stratégiques comme l'action
économique ou d'autres et qui ont plutôt
une vocation à échoir à la strate
intercommunale et deuxième question
parce qu'elle est souvent abordée en
creux de de vous contributions les uns
et les autres c'est la relation à l'état
vous vous l'avez dit c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a de moins en moins de
de recettes de dotation émanant de
l'État et tout ça est complexifié parce
qu'on est face à une politique d'appel à
projet dont on a pas nécessairement
l'ingénierie pour y répondre et souvent
on voit passer le train malheureusement
parce que les les gros peuvent répondre
et les plus petits le secteurs rural ou
les communes qui ont des petites
centrales
aux grosses aux grosses communes aux
grosses intercommunalités et ça c'est un
vrai sujet parce qu'on voit la
difficulté notamment de capter celle des
dotations classiques que sont la dltr la
des cils ou au rendez-vous vous avez
évoqué petite ville de demain et donc
l'un des sujets aussi qu'on poursuit
c'est de voir comment on peut fluidifier
tout ça et comment on peut éviter à
chaque fois
de vouloir créer des décatégories des
appels à projets mais d'avoir peut-être
quelque chose de plus fluide une
dotation plus globale qui serait aux
mains des des préfets mais qui iraient
peut-être plus facilement
à destination des communes avec plus de
réactivité et moins de conditionnalités
ce qui trop souvent ralentit ce selon
moi et selon beaucoup d'entre nous
l'action l'action publique et la vie de
nos communes donc si vous avez là aussi
des réflexions à nous livrer peut-être
laisser la parole au collègue qui sont
qui sont ici Jean-Michel oui merci
monsieur le rapporteur présidente merci
à tous les collègues maires de France de
France montagnarde
de cette exprimé cet après-midi
un deuxième volet de notre mission
d'information concerne la fonction mère
est-ce que vous avez au vu de votre
expérience de vos questionnements
d'exercices de mandat et peut-être de
questionnements sur l'avenir au de la
2026 de votre engagement municipal des
suggestions spécifiques des retours
d'expérience sur le cadre de l'exercice
votre mission notamment le cadre
statutaire quels sont les éléments selon
vous qui vous faciliteraient de la vie
dans l'exercice votre mandat d'un point
de vue statutaire statut de l'élu cadre
cadre d'exercices de vos fonctions y
a-t-il des sujets sur lesquels vous
souhaitez alerter la mission
d'information merci
peut-être madame Sagna qui pourrait
répondre
sur le statut non je moi c'est surtout
vraiment
je tout ce qui a été dit est très
important comment conjurer cette
menuisement de du pouvoir des mers et
comment leur restituer toute toute leur
mission ça je pense que c'est très
important et ça passera obligatoirement
par des discussions et des réflexions
sur la limitation des compétences
transférées je pense qu'il faut
réfléchir la question et et que sans
cela parce que c'est quand même le
leitmotiv qui qui réunit toutes les
discussions c'est autour de ces liens
très compliqués cette dilution du
pouvoir et c'est transferts de
compétences donc je voulais je voulais
en profiter pour remercier
les élus de la montagne et qui se sont
battus pour obtenir que les stations
classées puissent garder la compétence
tourisme nous avons donc un office
communal il n'y a pas le jour où qui ne
nous en félicitons pas parce que le
maire il a besoin justement d'avoir un
bras armé pour agir c'est lui qui donne
la couleur la signature la voix de sa
ville et c'est très important en matière
de tourisme et pourquoi pas
dupliquer ce genre de dérogation voilà
sur le statut je n'ai pas assez
d'expérience pour en parler mais je
voulais vraiment dire que que le maire
c'est le maillon de confiance et que le
législateur doit absolument tout faire
pour lui rendre ses prérogatives
merci beaucoup oui
une suggestion également qui n'est
peut-être pas la réponse à la question
précédente mais un point qui nous réunit
tous aussi c'est que nos communes de
montagne nous représentons des habitants
mais on l'a vu dans plusieurs
présentations nous représentons des
territoires et je trouve que la loi n'a
jamais réussi à prendre en considération
le fait qu'un maire on représente certes
des habitants parfois peu nombreux mais
on représente on l'a vu avec le cas de
l'Ardèche des territoires importants sur
lesquels il faut organiser les services
et si un jour la loi pouvait être
modifié dans ce sens et qui est une
prise en considération des territoires
que nous représentons je pense qu'on
aurait aussi fait un pas en avant
deuxième interrogation est-ce que dans
ce débat on parle de des présidents
d'intercommunalité et de leur éventuelle
élection au suffrage universel parce que
là aussi les choses ne sont pas sur le
même plan au vu des budgets importants
que nous gérons à l'échelle
intercommunale des compétences
importantes et ce qu'on s'oriente aussi
vers vers cette possibilité pour ce qui
serait aussi pour l'avenir de la commune
et l'avenir du maire c'est aussi une une
question qui qui se pose voilà je
voulais juste ajouter c'est ce point
vous avez raison d'insister sur le sur
le il y a le paramètre habitant mais il
y a le paramètre effectivement surface
du territoire néanmoins je m'interroge
et ça pas été ça a pas été évoqué je
sais où combien la question est délicate
mais nous sommes là pour défendre dans
les communes nous avons essayé d'être le
plus
pesant dans nos arguments pour pour
cette défense
néanmoins y a-t-il une carte communale
qui n'est pas à revoir moi je vois que
dans ma commune donc de 377 habitants
nous sommes entourés de trois autres
communes dont l'une à 14 habitants et un
conseil municipal une autre une
trentaine est-ce que mais c'est une
simple réflexion que
donc j'ai pas la totalité de la de la
réponse mais est-ce que quand les
communes ont si peu de population il n'y
a pas à gagner de renforcer la commune
voisine que
que de faire
survie mais je sais combien c'est
délicat monsieur le sénateur des Alpes
et puis je sais que pour les pour un
sénateur c'est pas c'est pas un sujet
facile puisque vous risquez d'être mais
enfin peut-on défendre ils ont la bruit
11 habitants
je vais même pousser plus loin comme off
mais
l'indemnité de maire dans ces petites
communes et souvent dévoluent à un
agriculteur qui trouve là RSA
complémentaire et ça peut-être aussi il
faut avoir le courage de le regarder en
face est-il maire pour cette
rémunération complémentaire est-il mère
réellement pour l'être y a-t-il une
légitimité est-ce qu'il le soit je vous
demande pas de répondre parce que vous
couperez voilà je vous demande pas de
réponse vous mettriez en difficulté pour
les prochaines éditoriales mais
comment
non cette femme sans commune mesure avec
le reste je suis d'accord avec vous
[Musique]
mais alors dans ce cas-là on admet que
c'est un système parallèle de soutien à
leur ruralité il nous reste cinq minutes
donc on va demander et je crois qu'il
reste trois mères
n'ont pas répondu
[Musique]
de la préfecture et de la police et puis
le la partie investissement alors moi
j'ai une petite suggestion sur ces
histoires de detrdsl on avait une
réunion hier des présidents de des
associations de maire eurodronnantes je
n'arrive pas à comprendre que on n'est
pas un cadre de guerre qui soit
identique par tout en France et que dans
chaque département il puisse varier
alors que comprennent des choses et
qu'on les prenne pas mais par exemple
nous on Ardèche on n'a pas du tout
devoirie et mon collègue de l'Allier
m'expliquait qu'ils ont réussi à mettre
10% de la DETR sur l'avoirie communale
et en particulier ils ont limité ça aux
communes de 300 habitants alors c'est
peut-être quelque chose à soulever à
essayer de faire intégrer pour que dans
toutes les dottr on puisse avoir cette
compétence minimale de l'eau et de la
voirie puisque c'est deux compétences
qui nous restent et qu'il faudra bien
assumer parce que sinon on pourra plus
circuler chez nous et on pourra bientôt
plus boire voilà c'est peut-être un peu
ça et puis moyennement d'accord sur
l'imposer aux petites communes de
fusionner avec sa voisine parce que je
pense que les Français sont encore pas
prêts les mers non plus et puis tant
qu'on impose ça marche pas donc moi j'ai
un cas dans notre communauté de communes
on a une petite commune qui a fusionné
avec sa voisine mais c'était la volonté
des deux et du coup ça a très bien
marché si on l'impose on sait bien que
ça marche pas comme le transfert des
compétences qu'on veut nous imposer il
marchera pas si on nous impose si on
ouvre l'impose pas peut-être que les
maires feront transfert automatiquement
et dans la douceur et tout se passera
bien voilà
rapidement monsieur mir c'est quelque
chose
que le propos concernant la fusion des
communes bon moi je suis d'accord
effectivement il faut que ce soit
quelque chose qui soit ni possible sur
la base du volontariat ça ça me paraît
préalable vraiment
absolu bon actuellement si ça quoi on a
des maires de petites communes qui ont
les pires difficultés pour trouver une
secrétaire
donc je crois que la solution
effectivement c'est le mutualiser les
moyens et je crois qu'il faut faciliter
la fusion des communes bien souvent
c'est pas forcément problème financier
c'est un problème d'identité dans la
mesure où les petites communes en fait
leur préoccupation leur souci c'est de
perdre leur identité et ça c'est des
choses à mon avis qui peuvent être
résolues mais il faudrait qu'il y a un
régime quand même plus incitatif pour
faciliter cette fusion de fusion de
communes ensuite je voulais revenir sur
la question qui a été posée concernant
la manière de rendre la fonction des
mers plus attractive bon je crois que ce
qui est véritablement décourageant c'est
l'aspect au delà des responsabilités
c'est l'aspect chronophage je vois mal
comment un jeune chef d'entreprise et
qui s'investit dans son entreprise peut
dans le même temps
occuper une fonction de maire c'est
juste pas possible le nombre de réunions
c'est quelque chose
vous avez évoqué la question je
regardais mon calendrier aujourd'hui
j'ai huit réunions rendez-vous voilà
mais je pense que la plupart des maires
sont confrontés à cette difficulté après
c'est vrai il y a la question de
l'indemnité qui sont des indemnités que
je qualifierais de Family que je veux
dire c'est un rapport et sans aucune
mesure avec le temps que nous y passions
et les responsabilités qui sont les
nôtres voilà donc je pense que la
réflexion elle est amenée effectivement
sur le fait de savoir comment rendre
cette fonction plus attractive et c'est
l'enjeu de la prochaine échéance de 2026
merci on termine avec Madame Portugal
juste un petit mot justement au sujet de
l'indemnité j'étais avec mes collègues
mère femme mère en s'est réunies le 8
mars du haut du département du Nord du
département des Hautes-Alpes et les
mères des petites communes 300 habitants
de m'ont dit c'est très difficile de
trouver du travail quand on est mère
d'abord il faut qu'elle travaille parce
que c'est 800 euros d'indemnité et c'est
pas beaucoup 300 habitants et elle elle
avait du mal à trouver du travail pour
compléter ça parce qu'elles étaient
maires leur mandat de maire était un
frein quand elle disait qu'elles étaient
mère et ça c'est quelque chose de enfin
pour moi c'est quand même aussi un frein
voilà
peut-être juste pour répondre à la
première et à la dernière réflexion
contribution on avait essayé dans
latexte engagement et proximité de
prendre en compte ce sujet je pense que
ça nous invite aussi à évoquer la
question du statut et de la disposition
en terme de nombreuxeurs parce
qu'effectivement c'est trop souvent un
frein pour les mères mais aussi pour
celles et ceux qui vous accompagnent
adjoint à voir conseiller délégué dans
des communes plus importantes quant à la
question de la prise en compte des
kilomètres carrés si je peux le dire de
façon aussi brutale que ça le Sénat a
beaucoup travaillé sur le sujet et nous
avions proposé dans le texte que vous
avions déposé à l'époque avec Philippe
Bas le fait que puisse pris en compte
notamment pour la gouvernance des
intercommunalités la question du
territoire pour se faire il faut qu'on
introduise un versant constitutionnel et
qu'on ait une réforme constitutionnelle
qui nous permettra notamment de revenir
sur la représentation au sein des inter
mais aussi le territoire étant pris en
compte de pouvoir travailler notamment
sur la définition des dotations et de
tout ce qui participe justement
pleinement de de la vie des des communes
comme comme les vôtres et ça je pense
que c'est quand même relativement
important pour tous les exemples que
nous avons eu aujourd'hui en tout cas
remerciements à chacune et à chacun
d'entre vous de vous contributions
précieuses et particulièrement
éclairante qui convergent ailleurs sur
beaucoup de points quel que soit
d'ailleurs vos territoires
merci merci ben écoutez on va pouvoir
clôturer notre notre table ronde merci à
vous d'avoir été présent et à ceux qui
sont en vision de nous avoir consacré un
petit moment moi ce que je veux juste
vous rappeler c'est que c'est important
pour nous aussi d'avoir votre regard
spécifique avec vos spécificités de
montagnards ces communes qui ont qui
subissent des variations de population
en très peu de temps selon les saisons
c'est communes qui ont des équipements
très spécifiques à mettre en place aussi
en fonction de ces variations de
population ces communes ou il y a aussi
je pense la responsabilité qui est
décuplée par rapport à une commune
classique ne serait-ce que quand on gère
des stations de ski ou des
établissements thermaux ou de les deux
là on est sur sur des questions de
responsabilité y compris pénales sur des
des communes aussi qui ont des handicaps
liés aux risques au risque majeur au
risque d'inondation de gisement de
terrain et tout ça c'est important pour
nous aussi de voir que ce ne sont pas
forcément ces responsabilités là qui
sont des freins pour vous et qui vous
empêchent de vous de vous consacrer à
vos communes vous avez juste aussi
parler de de ces deux fameux irritants
que l'on a aujourd'hui avec le zan et
l'eau potable sachez que la semaine
dernière nous avons passé deux
propositions de loi au Sénat sur ces
sujets là proposition de loi de
Jean-Yves roux sur le retour à
l'optionnalité de la compétence au
potable et assainissement et sur le zan
la proposition de loi blanc l'État qui
qui revient aussi sur une une garantie
rurale de un hectare par commune par
commune donc ça c'est le Sénat essai de
travailler mais franchement on se sent
pas forcément écouté de l'autre côté la
barrière du Parlement voilà merci en
tout cas à vous et bon retour dans vos
territoires et je salue léo-pyrénéens et
l'Ardèche en vis io merci à tous
merci
[Musique]